make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking up with venom volume 2
which is oversight this is actually
pretty cool alright here's it here's the
funny thing about this and this again
like we've talked about this before and
we're gonna kind of rehash this a little
bit again just for for people who are
new so the idea behind this is that this
is in a lot of ways kind of a soft
reboot but it comes off the heels of
really like one of the biggest changes
in like the whole spider-man slash venom
mythos which was part of Marvel legacy
and like the death of Flash Thompson the
idea behind this is that again you know
because it's a second volume kind of
comes off the heels of the first which
is to say like the death of the venom
God but at the same time the events of
like Eddie Brock now of course with it
only being Volume one we kind of assumed
that like Eddie Brock and the venom
Samiha wouldn't actually be killed
instead it was just kind of left on this
sort of ambiguous tone of like what will
happen next and so what this does is it
picks up with like some guy who's
basically speaking directly to Eddie and
it seriously kind of rapping you're kind
of running over like the things that
happen and from the perspective of Eddie
the way this played out is that Eddie
Brock himself along with the venom
simian had destroyed like no the venom
God and then like that was the end of
that and then basically like the Venom's
to me it seems to have either been
killed or like out of commission and
then somewhere along the line Eddie
Brock just like woke up in this place
where this guy's essentially talking to
him wanting to know where the sample and
the reason why was because after venom
and and Eddie Brock had defeated know
somebody came along and then gathered a
sample of the Venom symbiote but Eddie
himself has no idea where the Venom
symbiote is and when this guy starts
referencing things like project Pegasus
and starts talking about hey like I work
for an organization and things along
those lines
Eddie's assumption is that it's shield
and the reason why is because one the
suit this guys wearing bears the color
scheme of shield and two because this is
how shield would do things but then we
end up finding out that this guy is
actually the maker now the maker has
been a free-floating character in Marvel
Comics for really for like four years
ever since Secret Wars happened in 2015
Marla's never really done anything with
him and it's one of those funny
situations because the maker came around
so close to the end of the ultimate
universe and like the launch of seeker
Wars it was one of those things were
like when secret wars happen and like
the multiverse collapsed and then it was
all recreated by the main Marvel
Universe Reed Richards the maker was
just kind of floating around there and
anybody could have done anything with
him ultimately they didn't these just
kind of there for like a villain I think
unlike the New Avengers with Robert
decosta and then like that was it it was
a couple of their appearances here and
there and this is really like the next
instance where he's being used but the
idea
that makers essentially working for an
organization which initially took the
sample of the Venom symbiote after you
know everything happened with null and
then somebody stole it from Reed and so
that's kind of the question is who was
it that took it who was the stolen and
their assumption is that it's Eddie
Brock and the way that maker Connor
talks here is that Eddie Brock's not
fully aware of what's going on and
that's kind of the irony here because we
always sort of assume that even if Eddie
Brock doesn't recall everything what he
forgets the Venom symbiote remembers and
that's where the question kind of comes
in to you of like where's the Venom
symbiote and all of this and that's what
it sort of comes to an explanation
because what the maker does is basically
say what actually happened here is not
what you believe what you believe is
that you defeated null and the Venom
symbiote wasn't it wasn't answering you
when you were talking to it you kind of
collapsed you thought you died and then
like you woke up here some time later
what he basically says is it's been five
weeks since the defeat of no and it's
kind of crazy because what he says is
like win that all habit and my guy
showed up in order to take a sample all
hell broke loose like the venomous
images kind of reacted instinctively
bonded itself to you killed like four of
my men and then took off and for the
next three weeks we had no idea where
you were it took us forever to track you
down but when we did we tracked you down
to your father's house
and it's kind of a cool theme because of
the question Eddie Brock has and the
question we as the reader have is why
the font why the house of his father and
of course that'll be explained later on
but at the moment it's just kind of like
why I've I this of all places because we
know the relationship between Eddie and
his father it wasn't like the greatest
thing ever
now of course ultimately he was caught
and he was brought here but five weeks
have passed it's been three weeks on
while he was on the run and for the last
two weeks he's been here and so what
seems to have gone on is that there's
been this kind of cyclical pattern that
like Eddie Brock has brought in Eddie
Brock is interrogated and then for some
reason that's never fully explained the
venom Samiha plays his kind of role as
protective for Eddie and then wipes his
mind of the memories of what he's been
experiencing for the last two weeks and
so effectively every day is the first
day every day is the new day for for
Eddie it was kind of a cool thing here
because what what Reid kind of
speculates here and it's one of the
things he doesn't really even know what
what maker kind of speculates here is
that like because the venom simian is
all for all intents and purposes brain
dead what it means is that it's just
kind of like wiping sections of his mind
away it's playing the role of a
protector it's never actually left Eddie
it's been with him the whole time but
it's kind of a crazy thing and the
reason why I say is a bit of a soft
reboot is because what Donny Kate seems
to be doing here is essentially kind of
wiping away a lot of the venom stuff
that came before him which is to say the
personality of venom the idea that like
it relates to the host like it was a bad
guy
when it first bonded to Eddie then it
became a good guy when it bonded to
Flash Thompson and now it you know they
don't want to kind of maintain the good
guy role as part of Eddie now it's just
kind of being just an organism that's
there and what it does is it kind of
sets the stage for Donnie Cates to go in
a couple different ways either he can
bring it back and kind of return the
personality of the venom Samiha kind of
turned this into like an ark really more
for the symbiote than for Eddie kind of
like its death and rebirth or he could
build it up into something else
completely but the explanation that's
given here is that the venom CIMMYT was
able to maintain its autonomy able to
kind of maintain its personality things
like that because it was tied into the
hive mind of like all the Venom's and
the connection to that hive mind was
basically like the mind or the existence
of like this symbiote God but when no
was destroyed the connection went with
it and so basically this symbiote as is
bonded to any is just kind of a
free-floating item out there it's no
different than like a knife or a hammer
as it was kind of a crazy thing because
what what maker ends up doing is
basically saying hey look like along the
way we've learned little bits of
information here we've learned little
tidbits here and all this really kind of
comes out of the death of Flash Thompson
which is interesting because Eddie
didn't know the flash Thompson died now
the reason for that is because a lot of
that was kind of wrapping up the Flash
Thompson Ark which been going on for
quite some time like it really started
with agent venom maybe a little bit
before then and it had been running for
for more than a little bit but what this
did is it went into the events of Marvel
legacy and amazing spider-man number 800
which essentially had like Flash
Thompson his agent venom being killed
off and the reason why was because
during the whole red goblin incident
where you basically had like the carnage
symbiote bonded to Norman Osborn the
Green Goblin it kind of turned into an
almost like an Ultimate Universe Spider
Man scenario where like you had Green
Goblin as I guess really the red Goblin
basically like facing off against some
of spider-man foes and even some of
spider-man's friends and so on and so
forth but basically like Flash Thompson
made the choice to sacrifice his life in
order to save the friends of spider-man
and even spider-man himself using his
healing abilities and what that did is a
comet itched in stone the idea that
Flash Thompson was kind of like this
incorruptible beam right like you know
when he got the bit of semi and he
wasn't corrupted by it he wasn't screwed
up by it it became a good guy with it
it's kind of the idea that like Flash
Thompson is the basis behind what a hero
could truly be the cool thing about this
is that what maker does is he
effectively tells Eddie Brock that what
they've learned after taking a sample of
a Flash Thompson is they learned that
like when a symbiote bonds itself to a
house that it never actually leaves
entirely that when a symbiote leaves a
host for example when the Venom symbiote
left Eddie
so he left Flash Thompson what it did is
it left a cut of sample of itself on
flash Thompson's DNA and it's the way in
which they kind of communicate with the
hive mind right so it's like sending out
a beacon you know it's like planting a
flag on edit on Flash Thompson and
saying venom has been here like venom
was here and what it means is that by
doing that they could potentially clone
Flash Thompson or at the very least try
to understand like how this works in
terms of manipulating the human genome
and how the Venom's to me it impacts it
as it was kind of a crazy little
scenario here because what they're
looking to do what-what literally maker
wants to do and the guys he's working
with is they want to go to the military
cemetery and they want to dig up the
body of Flash Thompson
and this sends Eddie Brock into a frenzy
and this isn't a very very important
thing and the reason why is because
while Eddie Brock and venom weren't like
the best sir I'm sorry Eddie Brock and
flash were like the best of friends they
weren't besties or anything like that
they do share a commonality in the sense
that they were both host for the venom
simian but with flash learning I'm sorry
Eddie learning the means by which flash
basically died it's kind of like hey
look he was an honorable guy and I'm not
gonna let you go to a cemetery and dig
up the corpse of an honorable man not
only that even if the venom simian is
kind of brain dead meaning like its
personality and everything is gone on
some kind of rudimentary subconscious
level it does hanker for Flash Thompson
and it does recognize the value of Flash
Thompson and so to do this anger
sisimiut as well and literally it lashes
out and starts attacking the maker
giving Eddie the chance to kind of make
his escape now of course what it does he
basically runs into a you know some of
these soldiers using a sonic devices and
so on and so forth who look to take him
out but the cool thing about this is
that when that happens the vial
containing the DNA of Flash Thompson
essentially shatters bonds itself to
Eddie Brock and when it does Eddie Brock
bonds with Flash Thompson which is which
is kind of crazy because what this means
is that like you have flat you have
Eddie Brock here but you have Flash
Thompson talking to him the same way
that the venire Venom symbiote talked to
Eddie now this opens up a whole new host
of possibilities no pun intended because
what this means here is that by the two
of them working together it could be
that Flash Thompson understands the
sabia in a way that Eddie Brock doesn't
and the reason why is because while
Eddie Brock was host for the venom Samia
for a long long time a lot of the
evolution of the venom simian in terms
of what it's capable of what it can do a
lot of that really came through Flash
Thompson and so with flash really
understanding the venom simian on a much
deeper level than Eddie does in turn
like that information gets passed on and
it's a question of like what do we do
with this sin via now how do we kind
regain ourselves and so at the moment
essentially like Eddie Brock is agent
venom now Eddie Brock and Flash Thompson
merged and become the new agent venom
it's basically what goes on but it's
kind of a cool thing here because
following this it basically goes into
the question of again like who was it
that stole this symbiote sample of Eddie
Brock and that's what we kind of pick up
with the epilogue of all this with some
shady guy and like a giant torch walking
through this cavern basically but we end
up finding out the reason why this was
done was so that this new venom so I
guess as this venom soviet sample can
basically be bonded to Cletus Kasady
as it was kind of a cool thing because
what this means is that Cletus Kasady
the original carnage can make his return
but also he could be modified and become
like a new kind of symbian and that's
kind of a cool thing because the
question is like what would happen if
somebody with the Venom symbiote bonded
with somebody with the carnage symbiote
what kind of simian would that create
what direction will it take but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explained make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later purse
[Music]
you